before we get through the first half of
this century humans will be living and
working on Mars we can do it with the
kinds of technology either have today or
know how to build today let's think
about how we go about this thing okay
this journey to Mars there'll be a
series of robotic exploration steps
you send it those probes in advance you
land them we've seen orbiters to look
remotely robotically at its atmosphere
at its surface so it would be like an
exploration that you will do before you
decide on the human location well pre
positioning is a really the only
plausible way to do a manned mission to
Mars so we can send ahead of time or
they put them and the food and the
return vehicles some of that will have
to be land at first may have to be
robotically put together well that's it
gonna put these little components
together now put it all up or it may be
underground that's when you bend the
humans the humans are gonna go and
verify all the stuff that the robots
told us if you're going to Mars you're
not just gonna stick around for three
days you're gonna be there for months
and months and you need a lot of
supplies and you need a large living
accommodations the first humans who go
will probably descend to the surface and
they'll go and check into the habitat
and then you have series of robots that
the astronaut will be using to expand
search perimeter and we may have to do
it in stages where humans get down on
the ground live in a particular area
began to become acclimated and then
begin to really start a daily vigil of
work I envisioned that we would explore
Mars is that you'll have one location
like a station and we'll talk together
after a number of these things are done
we have a string of bases and after a
little while sending people to stay we
can have build in our time the first
human settlement on a new world there's
nothing in this that is fundamentally
beyond
technology all it takes is some focus
through a little bit of moxie we can do
this
you